hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about language learning as up as
a discovery in other words to me
language learning is not about how
quickly can I speak the language how
quickly can I get through this language
and learn some other language it's about
discovering the language and discovering
all the things that are part of that
language the people the history the
culture and I enjoy doing that and I
just want to illustrate this here over
the holiday period my son and his family
were visiting from England we had my
time we here we had got get togethers
all the time we had gifts of course and
he knowing my interest in Persian he
gave me a book which is the India in the
Persian of age from the year 1000 to
1765 and and the book describes the
tremendous influence of Persian culture
on India which began with an invasion a
Muslim invasion in the year 1000 of
turkic people hose I can remember what
they were called gals knee goes knee I'd
remember and they were very much
influenced by Persian culture and that
was sort of the beginning of a
significant influence of Persian culture
on India and in the at least in the
early part of the book he talks about
the sort of Persian influence as well as
a sort of Sanskrit based influence and
of course the Persian that influence
starts outside India and of course the
Sanskrit influence goes also outside
India and these are influences which are
you know they include lots of different
ethnic groups and and different
countries and it so forth so I'm looking
forward to getting into that and of
course because I start to learn person I
get interested in things Persian it's
important to realize especially today
with all the stuff that's going on
Persia 2,500 years ago Cyrus the Great
was this great tolerant ruler this was
at a stage when all of the Middle East
was under the Persians you know some of
the biblical figures and maybe even some
of the the origins of our
modern sort of Abraham based religions
start in this area who knows where in
Mesopotamia in somewhere in Anatolia
where there were variety of religions at
that time and Cyrus the Great was a
tolerant ruler and produced laws that
are you know still valid today I mean he
was a very great historical figure it's
important to understand a little bit
about Perga who which has gone through
all kinds of cycles as have all other
countries expanded its empire reduced
its empire over and other people got
over around my neighbors all this kind
of stuff so but it's not just history
it's also people so I have been in touch
with some people in Iran who have been
producing series for link called the
Iranians where Iranians talk about
themselves what they where they go to
school what they hope to do what they
like what they don't like what they like
to eat and so we've now got six of these
in our link library spoken first and
then transcribed please go and have a
look and I would love to have similar
monologues or dialogues in other
languages we are expecting some in
different forms of Arabic come the new
year but we are in the you later so you
know you know in the not-too-distant
future
so again discovering people I also
discovered that BBC has an excellent
podcast
Pargo I think it's pronounced and so I
have actually started sharing some of
these I had them transcribed and we're
sharing them I'm gonna try to get
permission from the BBC if they agree
we'll keep them there if not we may have
to remove them but we put them up for
now of course the whole Middle East is a
you know constant sort of neutral
influence of Arabic Turkish and Persian
so I've also put up some more Arabic
from fat cap which I've paid to have
properly transcribed which we're sharing
for now we're gonna try to get
permission from
similarly with al-jazeera so that you
can start to discover more of what lies
behind the language so to me you know
the important thing is that you know
it's not how quickly can I learn to
speak this language that's not the issue
it's not like three months I've learnt
the language now I can say if you think
that's not what it is it's about
discovering it getting a perspective on
you know cultures world events
modern-day world events history and
that's what makes language learning so
worthwhile
and so fascinating so and I think it's
it's important when we look at what's
happening today to remember that other
countries see themselves at the center
of the universe okay Europe may think
they're the center of the universe the
US might think it's the center of the
universe person might think it's the
center of the or Iran or the Arab world
or China or India I mean here's a lot of
cultures in this world and at various
times in history some have been more
powerful less powerful more influential
that's the world we live in and it's an
interesting world to discover through
language for now
[Music]